first of all Vince you came up with this
idea
how how does someone think of this idea
how did it happen but first we wanted to
do it long time ago because the French
guy did see me last 10 20 years ago why
he jumped from a plane and we went out
of the plane but we won't jump from one
plane to another plane no you've jumped
from the same plane and you rented the
same plane that's [ __ ] and that's
nothing there's nothing you what you
guys did was you took that and went much
further how do you come up with that
idea it was a dream so I was in Dubai
with Fred in my apartment I by the way
Fred and I we are not married we are
just roommate but you chit what you guys
do on your own time is your business and
you and your courage anyway I've this
dream I felt the dream that you had the
dream like I woke up in the morning
where I was jumping from the Montaigne
and reentering the plane so I go into my
living room and I tell Fred I just had
this idea where we were flying back to
the plane but jumping from the
maintainer and what it what did Fred
what was your response when Vince comes
running in and tells you this idea what
was your response no reaction no
reaction just staring at him I started
to think about it no way it was kind of
a scary at the beginning you know I just
could imagine like the environment like
a high Montaigne and the plane and
everything and like maybe heating the
plane and stuff like this and so guess
what
yeah hitting the propeller those are all
things that occur to me instantly yeah
and that's why I wouldn't even get out
of bed and tell anybody this idea but
you did okay let's take a look at the
stunt and then we'll talk about it and
we can talk through this you start by
let me let me see if I understand this
right you are on this mountain you both
jump off the mountains wearing your
flight suits and then the plane has to
get below you is that right yeah he's on
the side then we change side then we
have the pilot that gives us the go for
entry yeah at this point you take a deep
breath yeah and you go and then you take
a deep breath and then this is insane
this is madness and you get into the
plane
that's perfect
[Applause]
a lot of questions first of all what if
they had forgotten to open the door how
would you have had time to open it not
we would have knock on the door knock on
the door and then baby hello and then
write a little note okay how do you
train for something like that because
you are literally threading a needle the
plane is going 100 knots 100 miles Paul
100 miles per hour
I prefer knots but anyway hundred miles
per hour and you guys have to each
thread that needle how do you practice
something like that and not get hurt
first of all we practice jumping from
the plane and then we fly next to the
plane with a parachute a normal pair
shoes with Maine and a result and then
when we are ready with the environment
of the plane then we start the training
of going back in but to jump from the
Montaigne and to re-enter the plane it's
something that we do at the end that's
the finalized so you only did that once
we did it twice actually the first try
didn't we're good didn't work good
and you were both killed and now your
ghosts just that on it I'm trying to
picture what it's like when it doesn't
work I'm told you brought footage of you
guys trying and it not working out I
have not seen this but let's take a look
there you are and okay enough if we get
it oh my god that looks first of all how
did you live through that I mean you're
how hard are you hitting the side of the
plane it's not that bad actually well
what are you talking about it's not that
bad
where's the pistol is the plane made of
nerf moocher our speed is really
matching the speed of the plane you know
so when when we are approaching it's
only a few meters still it was it was
hurting a bit Wyatt you hurt your rib
yeah dr. Phil hurt his ribs in his
driveway his own driveway I think your
my rib got hurt story is much better
than doctor
I'm just saying it looks to me like you
hit and then you go spiraling off what
if you were knocked unconscious I mean
that's why you know we practice first
above a skydiving center with a main
parachute or reserve and the safety
device that can open your parachute if
you are knocked out oh if you're knocked
out it'll open up are directly when we
jump from the Montaigne we don't have
this device that's why we practice first
a lot and then we go to the Montaigne
when we are sure that we can make it in
okay let me pitch you an idea you guys
both jump out of a plane okay
in New York all right and you head
towards the Empire State Building and a
windows open you go in and an elevator
is waiting
would that work and you get in the
elevator and then it comes down to the
bottom and then you fly out when you get
to the bottom and get in a cab and you
take it to Staten Island
would that work let us think about it a
little bit but we will probably find the
team to make it work okay I've never
been humored so beautifully by anybody
here oh how to say that's that's
[ __ ] if you want okay
is this legal what you're doing by the
way but it's not legal it's not illegal
there is a let's forget this question
here is not written anywhere
I love you telling that to a policeman
li Gillis I did this forget this
question
you